there's this pipe dream of Bernie
Sanders and others that this will
somehow be paid for by the rich but
Sweden learned in the 1970s that you can
pick one a big generous welfare state or
you can make the rich pay for it all you
can't have both if you have a universal
generous welfare state uh in if and make
the rich pay for it all they will stop
being rich they will move they will stop
starting those businesses and the Ikeas
of the future will move again instead
you have to get most of the taxes from
low and middle income
households that's the Dirty Little
Secret of the Swedish welfare state
socialists love the poor taxpayers
because they are reliable loyal
taxpayers they don't Dodge they don't
move to Monaco they don't have tax
attorneys